Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Quiero que respondan
a la siguiente pregunta:
¿Tienen…?
No, esperen un momento.
Esto dice votación cerrada.
Vamos a ver si la puedo abrir.
Tienen…?
No, no funcionó.
Esto es lo más horrible
que me ha pasado en toda la vida.
Ok. Diapositiva actual.
[risas]
Bueno, me han pasado peores
cosas que esta, lo siento.
No quiero menospreciar a las
otras horribles cosas
que me han pasado.
Ok. Vamos a intentarlo otra vez.
Utilidades de los clickers, etc.
Ok. ¿Ya tienen clickers?
La votación está abierta.
Ok. Quedan 10 segundos para votar.
Verán esta cuenta regresiva.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4... ¡92! Muchos
ya tienen clickers.
Ok.
Veamos qué aprendimos.
Parece que el 97% de
ustedes tienen clickers.
[risas]
Comencé con este
ejercicio para destacar
un aspecto de las
investigaciones
psicológicas.
[risas]
Acabamos de cometer un error muy
clásico y peligroso,
conocido como sesgo de la muestra.
Usamos una medida que no nos da
información precisa
de lo que queríamos saber.
Queríamos saber,
qué porcentaje de las personas en
el salón tenían clickers.
En cambio, descubrimos qué porcentaje
de personas en el salón con
clickers tenían clickers.
[risas]
No sé quién votó que no tenía.
Este es un error muy peligroso y
podría haber continuado.
Supongan que después les pregunto
si son de la generación de
2014, 2013, 2012 o 2011
y hubiera descubierto que el 80% de
ustedes son de 1º y 2º.
También hubiera heredado
el error de sesgo
en la muestra que acabamos de ver.
Los de 1º y 2º ya
entregaron sus horarios.
Por lo tanto, ya están seguros de
las clases que están tomando.
Por lo tanto, es más probable
que ya tengan clickers.
Cuando hacemos investigación
empírica en psicología,
debemos tener muchísimo cuidado
con los medios usados
para elegir a los sujetos
para los experimentos,
para obtener una muestra precisa
de lo que nos interesa.
Hace poco apareció un
artículo en la revista
Behavioral and Brain Sciences titulado
"La gente más WEIRD (rara) del mundo".
WEIRD, por sus siglas en inglés,
significa en este caso:
occidental, culto,
industrializado, rico y
demócrata.
Es decir, los estudiantes
universitarios de Estados Unidos.
La gente con acceso a las
votaciones en línea por Internet.
El artículo explicaba
que una gran cantidad de
investigaciones psicológicas que
afirman
probar suposiciones generales
sobre la naturaleza humana,
están sesgadas de la misma
manera que mi votación
sobre el porcentaje de personas
que tenían clickers.
Observan una pequeña
muestra de la población
que está disponible fácilmente para los
laboratorios de investigación
en las universidades, por ejemplo,
los estudiantes de
introducción a la
psicología.
Y basan sus conclusiones sobre
la naturaleza humana
en esa muestra.
Durante el semestre,
debemos estar atentos cuando
leamos estudios psicológicos
que hagan afirmaciones sobre
la naturaleza humana,
porque es posible que
algunas cosas que digan
que aplican a los seres
humanos en general,
en realidad solo se haya
demostrado de forma concluyente
que aplican a los WEIRD:
sujetos occidentales, cultos,
industrializados, ricos y demócratas.
En ciertos casos, los resultados
serían muy distintos
si observáramos a otra población.
Esto también pasa con los
textos clásicos que usamos.
El proceso adoptado por
Platón y Aristóteles
no parecía experimental
desde el punto de vista de la
psicología experimental.
Pero, observaron una muestra de
gente a su alrededor
y basándose en su experiencia,
sacaron conclusiones sobre la
naturaleza humana.
Un pequeño recordatorio de algo
que dije en la primera clase
y a veces se olvida.
Por una parte, esta clase
es sobre filosofía
y la ciencia de la naturaleza humana.
Por otra, es sobre filosofía occidental
y la ciencia de la naturaleza
humana occidental.
Tenemos que tener esto en mente
cuando sea pertinente.
En la clase de hoy
quiero volver al tema que
abordamos la clase pasada,
el tema de la naturaleza
multiseccionada del alma humana.
Recordarán que la clase pasada
vimos la maravillosa analogía de
Platón sobre la razón,
el espíritu y el apetito,
representados por un auriga,
un caballo manso y un caballo salvaje.
Y otra serie de distinciones.
Cerebro izquierdo y derecho,
que logré decir mal 4 veces
consecutivas si no mal recuerdo.
Vimos la diferencia entre
el tronco cerebral
y el cerebro superior.
Vimos brevemente el concepto
freudiano del superego,
el ego y el ello.
Pero no pudimos abordar
la tradición del procesamiento doble.
En la clase de hoy,
vamos a continuar donde nos
quedamos la clase pasada,
con otra forma típica de
distinguir las partes del alma.
Permítanme aclarar que hay
suficientes fundamentos para
considerar
que la investigación que
voy a presentar hoy
no está sujeta al inconveniente WEIRD.
Es decir, ha habido pruebas
interculturales convincentes
de casi todos los resultados de
los que hablaré hoy.
También existen buenas razones
evolutivas para considerar
que los 2 sistemas que postulan los
teóricos de los sistemas dobles
son parte de cualquier ser humano
debido al proceso evolutivo
por el que todos nosotros hemos pasado.
Quería comenzar con una foto
de Edward Thorndike
no solo porque es una
persona muy importante
sino porque es guapísimo.
Es una imagen del archivo de la
Biblioteca Pública de Nueva York.
Edward Thorndike era un psicólogo
de finales del siglo XIX,
principios del XX, que hizo
muchos trabajos importantes
sobre el asociacionismo en animales.
También hizo investigaciones,
publicadas en un artículo en 1922,
que de cierta manera pueden verse
como el trabajo que funda
la tradición del
razonamiento que Jonathan
Evans
describe en el artículo que
leímos para la clase pasada.
En su artículo de 1922, describe
un experimento que realizó
llamado "El efecto del cambio de
datos tras el razonamiento".
Le interesaba estudiar si los problemas
formalmente idénticos que se
presentaban a la gente,
pero con variaciones en la
presentación del contenido formal,
eran procesados de forma distinta.
Preguntaba a la gente:
¿Cuánto es x+y al cuadrado?
(primero el exterior y luego el
interior, creo que así se hace)
O bien, ¿cuánto es b1+b2 al cuadrado?
Las personas consideraron
fácil la primera pregunta
y mucho más difícil la segunda.
El índice de éxito de x+y
estaba por encima del 90%.
El índice de éxito de b1+b2
era mucho más bajo.
O les preguntaba: ¿Cuánto
es a2x3 al cuadrado?
O ¿cuánto es r18r112 al cuadrado?
Y así sucesivamente.
Presentar a las personas problemas que
formalmente eran idénticos,
pero que cambiaban en
términos de complejidad
de los caracteres usados
para representarlos
producía una importante
disminución del desempeño.
Vamos a los años 60, 70 y 80,
cuando la gente comenzó a estudiar
el razonamiento silogístico
y surgieron una gran cantidad de casos
especiales de este fenómeno.
En el texto de Jonathan Evans que
leyeron para la clase pasada
vieron ejemplos como este.
Un silogismo que era válido y creíble,
es decir, cuyas propiedades
formales garantizaban
que si las premisas eran verdaderas,
la conclusión era verdadera ,
y de hecho, la
conclusión era
verdadera.
Y argumentos que eran
válidos pero no creíbles,
en los que la estructura del
argumento garantizaba
que si las premisas eras verdaderas,
la conclusión era verdadera,
pero la conclusión era falsa.
Por ejemplo, podrían decirles:
Ninguna tragedia griega es comedia.
Algunas comedias griegas son obras.
Y preguntarles si dado lo anterior,
algunas obras griegas no eran
tragedias griegas.
Ninguna tragedia griega es comedia,
algunas obras griegas son comedias,
por lo tanto, algunas obras griegas
no son tragedias griegas.
El 90% de la gente era capaz de ver
que ese argumento era válido.
Por el contrario, podrían
darles un argumento,
igualmente válido, pero con una
conclusión no creíble como:
Ninguna novela rusa es breve.
Algunas novelas de
Dostoyevski son breves.
Por lo tanto, algunas novelas de
Dostoyevski no son novelas rusas.
Es un argumento válido.
Es un argumento válido con
una conclusión falsa,
porque una de las premisas es falsa.
Debido a que la conclusión
era inverosímil,
solo el 55% de las personas
pudieron reconocer
que la conclusión se
deducía de las premisas.
Noten, sin embargo,
que estos 2 argumentos son
idénticos en su estructura.
Ambos tienen esta forma: Ningún A es B,
algunos C son B,
por lo tanto, algunos C no son A.
Las propiedades formales por sí mismas
no determinan nuestra capacidad
de juzgar la validez.
De hecho, también es cierto
que las propiedades
formales por sí mismas
no determinan nuestra capacidad
para juzgar la invalidez.
Mientras que los argumentos válidos
con conclusiones verosímiles
son juzgados como válidos
aproximadamente el 90% de las veces,
acabamos de ver que los
argumentos válidos
con conclusiones inverosímiles
son juzgados como válidos con
mucha menos frecuencia.
Un error contrario surge en el caso
de argumentos inválidos.
Los argumentos inválidos con
conclusiones verosímiles
son juzgados como válidos.
Se juzga que la forma del argumento
garantiza la veracidad de
la conclusión.
Resulta que lo que garantiza la
veracidad de la conclusión,
en ese caso, es simplemente la
información del mundo,
en vez de la información sobre la
estructura del argumento.
A la luz de esta
condición de Thorndike,
varios investigadores crearon
paradigmas de investigación
que demostraron esto que
acabamos de decir.
La famosa tarea de selección de
Wason pide a las personas
que determinen cuál de las 4
cartas necesitan voltear
para comprobar la veracidad
de una afirmación.
Por ejemplo, podría darles
esta afirmación:
"Si hay una A de un lado,
hay un 3 del otro".
Y podría presentarles 4 cartas
y preguntarles cuáles
necesitarían voltear.
Obviamente, necesitan voltear la A.
Todo mundo entiende eso.
Necesitan comprobar si hay
un 3 del otro lado.
Obviamente, no necesitan voltear la D.
Saben que las cartas tienen
una letra de un lado
y un número del otro.
Así que no hay la preocupación
de que haya una A al otro lado de esta.
Pero, las personas tienden a pensar
que necesitan voltear el 3 y que
no necesitan voltear el 7.
Pero miren.
Justamente al otro lado
del 7 había una A
y la afirmación resulta ser falsa.
Las cartas que necesitan revisar son
las que tienen la A y el 7.
La gente consideró que esta tarea
era un relativamente difícil.
Pero, aquí hay una tarea con
una estructura idéntica
que la gente consideró
relativamente fácil.
"Si una persona está bebiendo cerveza,
dicha persona debe ser mayor de 21".
Les muestro 4 cartas:
el bebedor de cerveza, el
bebedor de refresco,
el mayor de 21 años y el de 17 años.
Supongamos que cada uno de ustedes
consigue trabajo de cadenero en
un bar, entra al bar
y descubre que una persona de 17
años está bebiendo cerveza.
Así se dan cuenta de lo que era tan
difícil ver en el caso anterior,
que las cartas que necesitan voltear
son la primera y la última,
en vez de la primera y la tercera.
Ha habido todo tipo de
explicaciones hipotéticas
de por qué la segunda tarea es
más fácil que la primera.
Quizás, la hipótesis más
famosa es la propuesta
por los psicólogos evolucionistas
Leda Cosmides y John Tooby,
que afirman que tenemos en
nuestro interior
un módulo de detección de tramposos
y que somos muy sensibles
a casos que implican
violaciones a las reglas.
Noten que el segundo caso es
distinto del primero en 2 cosas:
En primer lugar, tiene arraigo social;
mientras que el primero es
meramente abstracto.
Descubriremos,
a medida que avancemos en nuestras
lecturas este semestre,
que el arraigo social despierta los
procesos de razonamiento
que de lo contrario no se darían.
La semana pasada aprendimos,
con el estudio de los ojos, que la
gente era más prosocial
y estaba más dispuesta a
seguir las normas morales
cuando había
representaciones visuales de
ellos,
como los ojos, en parte porque esos
ojos despiertan y activan
una especie de entendimiento
social que todos tenemos.
La primera diferencia entre el caso
de abajo y el de arriba,
es que el de abajo implica algo social,
mientras que el de arriba es
meramente abstracto.
La segunda diferencia, es por supuesto,
que el de abajo involucra una norma.
Se trata de cómo
deberían ser las cosas.
Mientras que el primero es
una regla descriptiva.
Se trata de cómo son las cosas.
La lección que podemos llevarnos
de la tarea de selección de Wason...
Para quienes estén interesados,
se han hecho miles y miles de
variaciones de ella
y son sumamente interesantes para
determinar exactamente
qué cosas de la tarea se le dan bien a
las personas y qué cosas no.
La lección que podemos llevarnos
es la que hemos enfatizado
a lo largo de esta clase y
de la anterior:
que tenemos formas de
procesar la información
que no siguen únicamente las
propiedades formales.
Y algunas de esas formas de
procesar la información,
implican alinear, por así decirlo,
lo que Platón llamaría
las partes del alma
que no han estado atentas a la
situación previamente.
¿Hay una pregunta por allá atrás?
Alumno: Sí, perdón por interrumpir.
Podría decir otra vez,
¿qué es exactamente lo que
tienen que hacer los sujetos?
No entiendo el diseño del experimento.
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: El
diseño del experimento
en ambos casos era: te dan
una afirmación
y tienes que comprobar su veracidad.
Te preguntan: "¿Es cierto que
si hay una A de un lado,
hay un 3 del otro?" "¿Es
cierto que si una persona
está bebiendo cerveza debe
ser mayor de 21?"
Tienes 4 cartas enfrente de
ti y te preguntan:
"¿Qué cartas necesitas voltear para
comprobar la afirmación?"
Para comprobar la afirmación,
"si hay una A de un lado,
hay un 3 del otro",
necesitas girar la A y el
7, no la A y el 3.
Eso debería parecerte más
obvio con el otro caso,
en el que para determinar si la
persona que bebía cerveza
era mayor de 21,
tenías que girar la carta
del bebedor de cerveza
y la carta de la persona de 17 años.
¿Quedó claro ahora?
[el alumno asiente con la cabeza]
Excelente.
Ok.
Los informes del procesamiento
doble intentan proporcionar
una explicación general
sobre lo que sucede
en los casos que acabo de describir
y en los que voy a describir ahora.
Sugieren que tenemos 2 mecanismos
relativamente autónomos
para procesar la información,
a los cuales se les han
dado varios nombres,
pero lo más normativo
es llamarlos simplemente
sistema 1 y sistema 2.
Mientras el sistema 1 es primitivo
en términos evolutivos,
porque usa las partes del
cerebro que aparecieron
al principio de nuestra evolución,
el sistema 2 es más reciente
en términos evolutivos, ya que implica
la función cortical superior.
El sistema 1 es
inconsciente o
preconsciente;
el sistema 2 es consciente.
El sistema 1 opera automáticamente;
el sistema 2 se controla
conscientemente.
El sistema 1 es natural, sucede
sin que nos esforcemos.
El sistema 2 implica esfuerzo,
en el sentido que implica un
gasto de energía cognitiva,
exige poner atención.
El sistema 1 es súper rápido.
Procesa la información casi
de forma instantánea.
El sistema 2 es lento,
relativamente hablando,
la información que obtenemos
del sistema 2 tarda más:
segundos en vez de milisegundos.
El sistema 1 es asociativo;
reconoce patrones en el mundo.
El sistema 2 se basa en las reglas;
puede aplicar principios.
El sistema 1, a veces dice la gente
que funciona por reflejo;
sucede sin reflexión, el sistema 2
se basa en la reflexión.
La distinción entre el sistema 1 y el 2
es el resultado de muchas décadas
de trabajo de mucha gente.
Aquí hay una tabla de otro
documento de Jonathan Evans,
lo pondré en el sitio del v2,
donde están algunos de
los investigadores
que han realizado trabajos
sobre el sistema 1 y el 2.
Quiero destacar algo muy importante:
es un poco engañoso hablar
de los sistemas 1 y 2
como si fueran cosas individuales.
El sistema 1 a veces es llamado
el conjunto autónomo de subsistemas.
Existe el procesamiento
visual, el auditivo,
el que nos da información muy
específica de las cosas,
por ejemplo, el reconocimiento de caras,
la longitud promedio de las líneas o
el que nos permite reconocer
algo como un depredador o
como una presa.
Todos esos sistemas tienen las
características que tiene el sistema 1.
Son rápidos, inconscientes,
primitivos desde el punto de vista
evolutivo y entran en
funcionamiento sin reflexión.
Pero la unión de todos ellos
no forma un sistema coherente.
Los informes del procesamiento doble
son una manera de intentar
dar sentido a un conjunto de fenómenos,
algunos tienen que ver con el
procesamiento del razonamiento y,
según aprendimos en el
maravilloso discurso
del Premio Nobel Daniel Kahneman
que les pedí ver para hoy,
algunos suceden en un dominio más
general del razonamiento.
He reproducido la magnífica
tabla de Kahneman
en la que explica su interpretación de la
relación entre el sistema 1 y el 2,
donde expone las similitudes entre la
percepción y la intuición,
por una parte, y el
razonamiento por otra.
Esta dispositiva también estará
disponible en el sitio web.
En la siguiente parte de la clase
voy a dejar la discusión de
Evans, que de cierta manera
dejamos pendiente la semana pasada
para conectarla con esta,
y pasar al trabajo de Daniel Kahneman
y su colaborador Amos Tversky.
Ahora tendrán otra oportunidad
de usar sus clickers.
Solo vamos a hacer otra
prueba hoy y si funciona,
tendremos un montón de
votaciones el siguiente martes.
Bien. Este es un problema de una
famosa enfermedad asiática
planteado por Kahneman y
Tversky, y dice así:
Una fatal enfermedad ha atacado a
600 personas en tu pueblo.
Si no reciben tratamiento
todas morirán.
Tú eres el alcalde y hay 2 opciones
de tratamiento disponibles.
Si la inicial de su apellido
está entre la A y la L,
tendrán que leer la información que
pondré en el recuadro verde.
Ustedes miren hacia este lado
y solo lean lo que aparezca
escrito en el recuadro verde.
Si su apellido comienza con M a Z,
van a leer la información
del recuadro azul.
Vamos a usar este código
de color siempre,
si esto funciona,
el grupo de A-L usará "1" para
"Sí" y "2" para "No",
el grupo de M-Z usará "3" para
"Sí" y "4" para "No".
Los del grupo M-Z miren el recuadro azul
y preparen sus dedos en el 3 y 4.
Los del grupo A-L miren
el recuadro verde
y preparen sus dedos en el 1 y 2.
Le pedí ayuda a Marvin Chun para
hacer diapositivas como esta
y sugirió esto.
Ok. ¿Listos?
Les voy a decir el plan A y el plan B,
así que miren solo el lado
que les corresponde.
¿De acuerdo? Lean el plan A.
Ahora lean el plan B.
Bien. Preparen sus clickers.
El equipo verde use "1"
para elegir el plan A
y "2" para elegir el plan B.
El equipo azul use "1" para
elegir el plan A
y "2" para elegir el plan B.
Ok. Voy a poner el temporizador.
Tenemos 64, 66... montones y
montones de respuestas.
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Aquí están las cantidades.
Ok. En el equipo verde, 40%
eligió el plan A.
En el equipo azul, solo 26%
¿Ay, saben qué? Esto en realidad no...
El tamaño de la barra es relevante,
pero está dividido en 100.
Tengo que aprender un poco más
sobre el uso de los clickers.
Permítanme reagrupar y explicar otra
vez lo que quería explicar.
Como podrán ver, en el equipo verde,
la preferencia relativa por el plan A
excedió la preferencia
relativa por el plan B.
Mientras que en la otra mitad tan
reducida de la clase...
el problema es que el 60% de
ustedes están en el equipo A-L
y solo el 40% están en el equipo M-Z.
Este es un nuestro problema.
Ok.
Pero en este grupo, si pudiera
calcular rápidamente 26 x 0.4,
podríamos descubrir el
porcentaje relativo.
En este grupo, la preferencia
relativa es por el plan B
en vez de por el plan A.
Sin embargo, noten que el plan A
y el B son idénticos.
Hay 600 personas.
En el plan A, 200 vivirán;
es decir 400 morirán.
De este lado, hay 600 personas.
Si elegimos el plan A, 400
personas morirán,
es decir, es seguro que 200 vivirán.
Sin embargo, los resultados que
ustedes muestran aquí
son el típico conjunto de resultados.
Normalmente, cuando las
personas tienen un problema
que implica elegir entre una
opción segura y otra probable,
enmarcadas en términos de sus
resultados positivos,
van a preferir el plan seguro
en vez del arriesgado.
Mientras otras personas con
el mismo problema,
pero centradas en la certeza de
que 400 personas morirán,
tenderán a elegir la
opción probabilística.
Noten, otra vez, que el plan A y el B
en ambos lados son idénticos.
Solo que uno está enmarcado en
términos de cuántos vivirán
y el otro en términos de
cuántos morirán.
El resultado es prácticamente
una inversión total
de las preferencias de la gente.
Obtenemos este tipo de efectos
según el marco de referencia
en repetidas ocasiones.
Aquí hay un estudio de un alumno
de Kahneman y Tversky,
Eldar Shafir, de principios de los 90.
Van a una heladería
y quieren comprar 2 sabores de helado.
Un sabor es bueno, pero el
otro es excelente
y tiene altos niveles de colesterol.
Descubren que solo tienen dinero
suficiente para comprar un sabor.
Si les pregunto cuál sabor prefieren,
el 28% elegirá el sabor bueno
y el 72% el excelente
con altos niveles de colesterol.
Pero si les pregunto a qué
sabor renuncian,
el 55% renuncia al sabor bueno
y el 45% al sabor excelente con
altos niveles de colesterol.
Aunque en este caso, el 28%...
Aunque ambas preguntas son
iguales, ¿cuál sabor eligen?
Si eligen A, renuncian a B.
Si eligen B, renuncian a A.
Pero los números no coinciden.
Cuando les preguntan cuál eligen,
el sabor excelente domina
y lo eligen, ignorando el colesterol.
Cuando les preguntan a cuál renuncian,
el del colesterol domina.
Este fenómeno se presenta
una y otra vez.
Supongamos que van al cine
y cuando llegan se dan cuenta de que
perdieron algo de su cartera.
Lo que perdieron puede ser
un billete de 10 USD
o una entrada para el cine,
con un valor de 10 USD,
que compraron la noche anterior.
Llegan al cine, abren la cartera,
ya sea para sacar el billete de 10
USD para comprar la entrada
o para sacar la entrada que
ya habían comprado,
pero descubren que han
perdido ese artículo
que les iba a permitir entrar al cine.
Sin embargo, tienen otros 10
USD en su bolsillo.
La pregunta es: ¿comprarían
otra entrada para el cine?
De las personas que perdieron el
billete de 10 USD en el camino
al cine, el 90% piensa: "Perdí un
billete de 10 USD, ¿y qué?
Voy a comprar la entrada con
el otro billete".
De la gente que perdió la entrada
con un valor de 10 USD,
solamente el 42% dijeron que
gastarían otros 10 USD
en comprar otra entrada.
El marco de referencia es uno de los
ejemplos de una heurística
o sesgo en los que Kahneman y
Tversky enfocan su trabajo.
Volveremos a otros ejemplos más
adelante en el semestre
cuando leamos el trabajo
de Cass Sunstein.
Ahora quiero que pongan atención a
un ejemplo en particular,
que va a servir como nuestro enlace
con el concepto de alief.
Es la distinción entre
frecuencia y probabilidad.
Supongamos que están intentando
conseguir una pelota roja
porque eso les permitirá
ganar un premio.
Tienen la opción de elegir de
la caja de la izquierda
que tiene 9 pelotas blancas y 1 roja,
o de la caja de la derecha que tiene 8
pelotas rojas y 92 blancas.
En la izquierda tienen 10% de
probabilidades, en la derecha 8%.
Van a sacar la pelota de la caja
con los ojos vendados.
Les recomiendo que no busquen una imagen
con esa descripción en Google.
[risas]
Busqué a la justicia con
los ojos vendados.
Y dio mejores resultados.
Bien.
Entonces, tienen que elegir.
¿Quieren intentar sacar la pelota
roja de la caja de la izquierda?
¿O quieren intentar sacar la pelota
roja de la caja de la derecha?
Obviamente, de forma racional,
tienen más probabilidades en la
caja de la izquierda.
Pero las personas se dividen
entre ambas cajas.
Tenían 10% de
probabilidades en la
izquierda,
¡pero en la derecha hay 8 rojas!
¡8! ¡8! ¡1! ¡8! ¡1! ¡8!
¡Más! ¡Más! ¡Más!
Lo que sucede, es que tienen la creencia
de que en la izquierda tienen
10% de probabilidades,
pero tienen un alief de que
en la derecha hay 8
y en la izquierda solo hay 1.
Alief es un concepto del que he
hablado en bloggingheads.tv
con Paul Bloom.
Aunque estábamos grabando en
distintos lugares,
yo estoy en la sala de juegos de
mi casa, atrás se ven
los rompecabezas geográficos, y
Paul está en su estudio.
Pero parece que nos separaron al nacer,
porque esta foto es del mismo momento
y esta otra es del mismo momento.
Bien.
[risas]
Supongamos que vamos al Gran Cañón
y los llevo a la plataforma de
cristal que se encuentra a 1.
2 km por encima del furioso
río que está abajo.
Se paran conmigo en la plataforma
y se quedan ahí de forma voluntaria.
Asumo que si permanecen
voluntariamente en una superficie
de cristal que está a 1.2 km por
encima del furioso río,
es porque creen que es segura.
Sin embargo, apuesto a que la
mayoría temblaría
y se estremecería.
Eso pasaría porque tienen lo que yo
llamo un alief que les dice:
"Estoy en el aire, a 1.2 km de altura,
sin nada que me sostenga y voy
a temblar de miedo".
O supongamos que estamos viendo
una película de vaqueros.
¿Alguien reconoce a este señor?
[foto de Ronald Reagan]
Chicos, era presidente
cuando ustedes nacieron.
Cuando ven una película de vaqueros
y las balas salen disparadas
en todo el escenario,
obviamente creen que están a salvo.
No piensan:
"Ay, qué bueno que las balas no se
salieron de la pantalla esta vez".
Sin embargo, especialmente en
las películas 3D,
moverán su cabeza para esquivarlas.
Si la baba verde de Green Slime
sale de la pantalla,
se estremecerán en sus asientos.
Si Anna Karenina está a punto
de morir, llorarán.
No porque crean que están en peligro
sino porque tienen un alief.
¿Cuántos adelantan su reloj 5 minutos
y luego restan 5 minutos?
Cuando lo hacen, creen que son las 10,
pero tienen un alief,
miran la hora y son las 10:05.
La información entra en su sistema
visual, se procesa rápidamente
y piensan: "¡Son las 10:05!
¡Me tengo que apurar!".
O supongamos que están viendo una
repetición de su equipo favorito
en la tele y saben que si uno de
los jugadores del equipo
intenta robar la segunda base,
le van a marcar un out.
Y gritan a la tele: "¡No
corras! ¡No corras!".
¿Por qué?
¿Porque piensan que su voz
atravesará la pantalla de la
televisión, viajará en el tiempo
y llegará a la primera base para
que el jugador la oiga?
No.
Tienen la creencia de que se
trata de una repetición,
pero su alief dice: "No corras".
Supongamos que están a dieta y
ven este delicioso trozo
de pastel de chocolate y tienen la
creencia de que no deben desearlo.
Sin embargo, su sistema alief, con la
forma del caballo platónico
podría arrastrarlos hacia el pastel.
[risas]
Supongamos que les presento
este pastel delicioso.
Esos son trozos de chocolate,
esto es un recipiente completamente
limpio y esterilizado, eso es coco.
De hecho, este tiene exactamente los
mismos ingredientes que el otro.
¿Me creen, verdad?
Soy su profesora, están aquí,
escuchando lo que digo.
¡Les digo que esto es comestible!
Chocolates, coco.
[risas]
Sin embargo, supongo que su sistema
alief se pone en marcha.
Supongan que les pido
firmar este contrato:
"Por medio del presente
afirmo que mi alma
te pertenece solo a ti, oh Satanás".
[risas]
Y escribo al final: "Esto no
es un contrato legal.
Es solo un mensaje para un
experimento psicológico".
No obstante, no querrán firmar.
No porque crean que es un
contrato legal, ¿verdad?
[voz muy aguda] "¡Dios mío!
Entregué mi alma al diablo.
Es un documento del diablo,
es un pergamino".
[risas]
No. Ustedes creen que no es cierto,
sin embargo, dudan.
Supongamos que los llevo al baño de
Monica Bonvicini, que es,
como pueden ver, completamente
opaco desde el exterior.
Se paran afuera del baño público,
lo miran y se dan cuenta
de que es imposible ver hacia adentro.
Tienen la creencia de que están
completamente protegidos.
Sin embargo, cuando entran
para usar el baño,
ven que por dentro es así.
[paredes transparentes]
Su alief hace que sea un
poco difícil hacer
lo que tenían pensado
hacer cuando entraron.
Supongamos que tenemos una bolsa de
azúcar y 2 vasos de agua.
Toman una cucharada de azúcar,
la echan en este vaso
y ponen la etiqueta de "azúcar".
Toman otra cucharada, la
echan en el otro vaso
y ponen la etiqueta de "veneno".
Ustedes echaron el azúcar en los vasos
y pusieron las etiquetas.
Sin embargo, las personas se niegan a
beber del vaso de "veneno".
No solo se niegan a beber de él
cuando dice "veneno",
también se niegan a beber
cuando dice "no es veneno".
[risas]
¿Por qué?
Porque la palabra veneno está ahí.
Entrando al sistema alief.
"Bien, azúcar.
Mmm bebo azúcar.
¿Veneno? ¿Veneno? ¡No
bebas el veneno!".
Bueno. Supongamos que tengo una cocina
y que quiero hacer un pastel que
parezca arenero de gato.
Entonces, tengo mis moldes para
pasteles guardados aquí.
Pero viene un chef y me dice que
sería mucho más eficiente
guardarlos a la derecha.
Se queda muy satisfecho con
lo que ha hecho.
Cuando le pido que me pase
el molde, dice:
"Me da gusto que hayamos pasado los
moldes al gabinete derecho".
Va a buscar el molde, creyendo que
estará en el lado derecho,
pero va justo a donde solía estar.
Cree que está en el lado derecho.
Pero su alief es un hábito persistente.
Quienes hayan cambiado de lugar
los muebles de su cuarto
conocen este sentimiento.
Quienes hayan estado buscando su celular
mientras lo tenían en la mano.
Yo he tenido miedo de haber
perdido a mis hijos
cuando en realidad los
llevaba en los hombros.
[risas]
Tener un alief es, más o menos,
tener una tendencia
mediada figurativamente
a responder a un estímulo aparente
de una forma determinada.
¿De acuerdo?
Por ejemplo, el estímulo aparente
de la plataforma de cristal,
el estímulo aparente del pastel
que parece arenero, etc.
Tienen una tendencia innata, como
en el caso del cristal
o del chocolate en forma de heces,
o una tendencia habitual, como en el
caso de ordenar la cocina.
Son formas habituales de
responder al mundo
que activan el tipo de
sistemas de bajo nivel
de los que hemos estado hablando.
Podemos reconocer un alief
más fácilmente
viendo estos casos discordantes,
son los casos en que sus creencias
les dicen hacer una cosa,
pero sus aliefs les dicen otra.
De hecho, el alief está
activo todo el tiempo.
Todas las veces que he pulsado
con mi dedo gordo derecho
el botón de esto, lo he
hecho por un alief.
Afortunadamente,
es un alief que se corresponde
con lo que quiero hacer.
Pero es cierto que gran
cantidad de nuestras acciones
están gobernadas por aliefs.
La pregunta es: siendo que,
como acabo de mostrarles,
hay cientos y cientos de
formas de describir
lo que yo considero que alude
al concepto de alief,
¿por qué introducir un nuevo término?
La explicación tiene que ver
con el alief mismo.
Cada 20 años aproximadamente,
el gobierno de los Estados Unidos
introduce una moneda de 1 USD.
Esta la introdujeron en 1921.
Esta la introdujeron en 1972.
Esta la introdujeron
después en los años 80.
Esta la introdujeron en 1980,
con Susan B. Anthony.
Esta es la de Sacajawea que
introdujeron en 2003,
y en un golpe de genialidad de
relaciones públicas, aquí está
la moneda de oro de Millard
Fillmore, que será emitida pronto.
¿Qué está pasando aquí?
Lo que pasa es que es difícil hacer
que la gente use algo
que no encaja en el sistema
monetario que ya tienen.
Las monedas de dólar no
encajan naturalmente
en la forma de usar el dinero
de los estadounidenses.
De la misma manera, hablar
de sistema 1 y 2,
sistemas relativamente
autónomos, la heurística,
los sesgos, etc., no encaja naturalmente
en la forma que hablamos de
nosotros mismos.
Hablamos de nosotros en términos
de creencias y deseos.
Para usar la moneda de oro,
que es el reconocimiento
del alma dividida,
necesitamos una idea que encaje en
nuestra moneda conceptual.
Espero que ese sea el papel que
jugará el concepto de alief.
El concepto de alief volverá a
presentarse en clases posteriores.
Volveremos a escucharlo en el
contexto de la armonía del alma
y en otros campos, escucharemos sobre
la heurística y los sesgos,
y escucharemos sobre el alma
de multiseccionada.
Espero verlos el martes en la clase
de Armonía y felicidad.